we are not here Stephen A to further
blame women that is not why we are here
it's just like you're not listening
excuse me excuse me I listen to you
you're the one telling me to stop on my
show it ain't happening
[Applause]
I approve email udoka who's the coach of
the Boston Celtics has now been
suspended for the entire NBA season
after reaching the NBA Finals with the
Boston Celtics last year
this year he won't even be on the bench
coach what happened Well turns out that
email udoka who was dating and seeing me
along Nia Long for a long time and had
two kids with her I believe they were
they were engaged
okay all right all right so this man
working at the Boston Celtics decided
that he was gonna have an affair with
two other staffers okay and this is
where things get weird apparently at
first it's consensual Boston Celtics get
out and they say you're suspended for
the year a lot of reactions towards this
him being suspended for a year I ain't
mad at it you're in the workplace keep
your [ __ ] dick in your pants and if
you're not going to keep your dick in
your pants please make sure it's with
somebody who's not in the workplace and
try not to [ __ ] the staff especially
okay
if you do get suspended no problem with
it all right get fired person I think
you'll be fired that's me personally
right reason being is from a corporate
standpoint uh one of your employees [ __ ]
another one then there's like raises
involved or promotions involved and she
claims that oh because I slept with you
don't want none of that drama no lawsuit
you got to get rid of you got to go you
gotta go
my only question is
if this was consensual
is not suspended too they're not
suspended they're not suspended
apparently they not even gonna get no
disciplinary action this is where things
get weird one of the women is the wife
of the vice president operations okay so
this idea that like this man's holding
power over one of them is like from a
whole different department stop it okay
it is what it is no no no no no no no
way it works and this was even my
workplace what that's not the way it
works go ahead
you get the man in power get out that's
the one that makes all the decision we
know that we know as a man that decided
we know we're the one with the magic we
go to a woman and we go and then we have
power over them yes why would she get
discipline in action
are you asking like jokingly you're
being serious
you're a joke uh no I'm asking in
where we live in in the present where we
live in right now
knowing that
the the the the only thing that is being
said is power dynamic
power dynamics so he's the head coach he
makes all the decisions it's really how
it looks like you know he doesn't he
doesn't make all the head coach he's
definitely involved but the head coach
is not the GM he's not the [ __ ]
president he is important he's powerful
but he doesn't run everything you have a
no fraternization policy unless that
person is your direct manager or there's
some implication that they held that
[ __ ] over you I don't care you get the
same punishment uh Malika Andrews had
something to say to Stephen a sir
Stephen A with all due respect
this is not about pointing the finger
what became apparent to me in this press
conference is that we do not have all of
the information here I think what stood
out to me is that Brad Stevens he was
upset that's what stood out to me about
what he termed uh rampant Twitter uh BS
is the word that he used that women were
unfairly dragged into this within the
Celtics organization you could see that
Brad Stevens was visibly upset he's a GM
and yes women were unfairly dragged into
it because you decide to keep the women
who engaged in consensual relationships
Anonymous so because you didn't say who
the ladies were who were also engaged in
the exact same type of [ __ ] okay
people are going to speculate they're
gonna Wonder they're gonna wonder why
these people are not being held
accountable so if Brad or anybody else
is mad it's because people are like wait
why are these ladies going out scot-free
when they also joined in on this
voluntarily
is that not fair absolutely it's not
like they give them grape juice you know
what I mean it's not what happened that
would have been a whole other situation
of course and that I would understand
where we're from you know I mean when
we're talking about that that's
something that's highly illegal whatever
we're not and I hope it would be more
than a suspension right and I can
understand that you would keep those
ladies Anonymous no but that is not the
case no this and I also found that to be
gross and unnecessary that folks were
bringing in the names and the images of
women that the fact that we are sitting
here debating whether somebody else
should have been suspended or not we are
not here Stephen A to further blame
women that is not why we are here we're
not here to further blame women no we're
here to blame people who should be held
accountable I don't care if you're a
woman don't care if you're a child don't
care if you're an adult granny trans
[ __ ] leprechaun don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you did something wrong you
should be held accountable man or woman
don't give a [ __ ] I have zero sympathy
for email udoka don't care about him for
you to sit here like we're not going to
blame it ain't about you having a [ __ ]
or not you should be held accountable
because you engaged in [ __ ]
that's it I'm so sick of being in
workplaces that have all these policies
to protect women fantastic I'm not mad
at them but then when women engage in
absolutely unethical behavior all of a
sudden the boss is like uh it's bad PR
so what
how is that fair to anybody else in the
workplace
anybody
I got to be held to the highest level of
scrutiny
she can go scot-free why because she
sees a gynecologist at one time a year I
don't care
sorry go ahead
uh yeah
um
you could go to the website for our
merch there's uh uh future is
accountability t-shirt there you can get
yours uh today so cop that Liza if you
want to put a whole Spiel basically in
vaginal terms what she said was
um the rules for thee not for me okay
and I think that's what it really comes
down to rule for the not for she didn't
have any rebuttal to why Stephen A May
said something wrong she just said we
are not that's not what we are gonna do
today that's not what we are going to do
today excuse me what that's not what we
are gonna do today
that what we are gonna do today we are
not gonna further further when did the
when did we [ __ ] start excuse me we
didn't even get out when did we start we
didn't cross the line [ __ ] you still at
the line
you've walked backwards you're not even
participating in the race we don't even
know your name
you're a shadowy locked character in the
video game we don't even know who it is
we supposed to play
hey why does it piss you off so much
if you've ever been in professional
settings and you've seen
and if you and you've seen some of the
[ __ ] double standards right
especially in the military when I was
coming through
you wouldn't believe ladies could get
away with murder bruh murder because at
the time from the pr standpoint they
didn't want no negative press right so a
woman just breathed in your direction
and you got to see HR
it happened to me it happened to other
dudes now of course those are
environments that are rampant with other
issues and I'm very sympathetic towards
that but I think it's unacceptable when
they engage in [ __ ] themselves puts
your whole career on the line and nobody
never held accountable murder
I'm talking about they get people
removed from that murder
and so when I see this it just reminds
me of that it's just like this is
patently unfair
right and so when dudes come out and say
you know what honestly don't feel like
working with women in the workplace and
everyone's like I'm like I get it I get
it it's less headache it's less headache
you don't have to deal with no [ __ ]
random out you don't have to deal with
No Nonsense you have to deal with no
fraternization unless [ __ ] is gay and
then you can just be like no lgbt2 if
you want to avoid that [ __ ] so so what's
your solution you you want like a
segregated workplace no that's what I'm
saying I'm saying I'm sympathetic to the
emotion listen we have ladies who work
for us I have no problems I can maintain
that workplace you know some very strict
guidelines in that regards right but I
can maintain that but I understand when
people say they don't want to yeah
because look at this two people engaged
in a consensual relationship only the
man gets blamed how does that make sense
do the math for me I'm very charitable
if he was the one in power of you if he
held whatever I understand that's not
fair if you're the secretary that you
want to keep your job and pay your bills
you gotta suck some dick yeah uh sorry
that's a problem
that's a big problem but if you guys are
just in the workplace you catch each
other while walking to the bathroom and
y'all decide to [ __ ] it's not because
the dude got a penis and all of a sudden
he deserves more that doesn't make sense
because that's exactly what they're
saying right now
how did that feel doing the first off
camera uh talk to me yeah now you know
my role right yeah you don't I see you I
know I was like this [ __ ] oh this this
[ __ ] is all you right now
taking that role sometimes going off
camera is not so bad right it's not so
bad yeah yeah you feel like a porn
director for some reason yeah yeah yeah
without the jizz and [ __ ] I mean hey if
I'm just masturbating is what it is it's
me by myself no
we are not here Steven A to further
blame women that is not why we are here
first of all
let me be very clear
I don't appreciate where you're going
with that I'm not blaming anybody but
eme udoker you know Stephen Stephen A
Steven sometimes I love sometimes I hate
him but [ __ ] you need to learn how to
spell some names bro this man be adding
syllables R's letters numbers and
syntaxes that don't exist in the [ __ ]
name who is IMEI udoker
even saying that since the NBA finals
but email you Joker
see you don't come with an art heart art
[Laughter]
dolker
you can't say that with the RR man it's
a hey God damn it Stephen [ __ ] he
deserves the fact of the matter is I've
said he deserved to be fired if they
were going to fire him if you're not
going to fire him then don't fire him my
issue is all of this being publicized
the point that I'm trying to make is
just
excuse me excuse me excuse me I listen
to you you're the one telling me to stop
on my show it ain't happening
that's right that's right that's right
yes I approve okay that's number one
number two I've already said he deserves
to be fired or he deserves what to to be
there and handle it internally and
privately if you're not going to handle
it privately if you're going to
publicize it in that fashion then
obviously it provokes everybody wanting
to know okay well who are the parties
involved I love the fact that she was
like well we're not gonna do is and then
he said well we're not gonna do is stop
me on my show that's great yeah
um yeah I mean listen
um
he can hold the big out he made you dug
a [ __ ] up his bag [ __ ] up his
potential career I'm sure I'll get a job
at some point in the future yeah but
yeah the whole double standard here
involved is like ridiculous and watching
all these companies virtue single
talking about we want to protect them if
you also want to protect women you need
to make them accountable for the fact
that they're engaging in these
consensual behaviors
you do so that they know it's a
deterrent in the workplace
shouldn't be that complicated
it shouldn't
um and then the last point I'll make and
this is the final one
we at some point are gonna have to have
a real conversation about the fact that
even though we put all these policies in
place people naturally are going to be
[ __ ] at work I don't like it I don't
think it's great but I also think if
you're being honest with yourself it's
very natural you're at work most of the
day you spend around most of my time
around these people and if you know
anything about the Sports World
journalists will admit to this most
people athletes all this stuff they [ __ ]
reporters they [ __ ] each other reporters
[ __ ] each other heads of basketball it's
not good it's a problem we can't just
say it's banned because at the end of
the day even though you banned it the
behavior doesn't seem to really stop
it's not because you ban something and
it
no it's not because you banned something
that you remove it okay you just deemed
it illegal
there's a lot of places that drugs are
illegal there's a ban on drugs
[ __ ] still use them yep there
was a whole prohibition Prohibition in
the states [ __ ] to use that it's
not because you ban something that is it
okay we banded people it is no longer
that's not how it works nope that's not
how it works
I'll take it a step further guys in the
comments leave a one if you guys have
been in a relationship or had a
consensual thing going on with somebody
from work leave a two in the chat if it
was unconsensual you're going to jail
leave a three in the chat if you've
never done that
if I see any twos you better unsubscribe
but the rest of y'all can subscribe
uh but that's pretty much it man yeah
let us know if you agree or disagree